but um
i was a second too late on withdrawing
from the tournament but milo 214
good luck good luck yeah i would like to
look at this game all right go for this
bishop's opening we'll play d4 this is
very nice this is called the
lewis gambit very nice blitz opening
trap you cannot take with the pawn here
you got to take with the bishop because
now there's this bishop takes f7
check fork on the king and the bishop
very
nice opening trap i've gotten hundreds
maybe thousands of players with this
trap queen takes c5 next we can pre-move
that
followed your club can i request a bird
opening
if you play white again uh yeah of
course man all right we've got d6 we'll
play
queen takes d4 picking up this pawn now
we're up upon black can't castle
and i think we'll play queen d3 now
maybe queen f3 next
um if something like knight before
and yeah we'll just continue
uh what's lm lee chess master yeah
i don't think lyches gives out the elite
chess master title
anymore
but they used to but not anymore
all right we'll just go queen back to d1
gotta stay defended to c2 and now
this knight is on b4 we have this option
of pushing a3
but first oh
this is actually getting a little tricky
now
all right we will
we'll pin this knight so that the knight
no longer attacks this pawn
and i think we will remove this knight
now
shall we gotta remove this knight and
then play a3 next
just kicking this knight back we could
play queen f3 next just look to trade
queens we are up a pawn
so i'm okay going into this
endgame we will isolate this pawn here
and now i think knight d5 is a fork
there we go fork on the f6 and c7 pawns
we got to challenge two so after this
game that walks in
right walks right into the king fork and
black resigns alright
good game